it was mimetic after all this all began
with felt to finding booted out of the
foundation I started working with dr.
pang five years after I got my
bachelor's and getting recruited because
of my [ __ ] Lord and although it was a
charming guy humorous but never losing
his cool and works really hard it stayed
this way until Oh 1020 years in he
claimed he was under the effect of stone
in his desk a stone that causes people
to lose interest in work to lose
willpower for innovation a
procrastination Rock Maggie and I
thought it was a joke wasn't the first
time dr. van created a fictional SCP to
scare us we didn't conduct any research
on it after all how can you research and
non-existent joke the joke was forgot
just below the stone itself after a few
days I would not remember the stone
until many years later dr. fangs started
to make mistakes he'd never made a
misplace book he ran over time bigger
there he's always explained away with
wave of her hand he was an old man after
all
then came the rush reports the missed
meetings the general lack of work done
his powers were taken positions degraded
yet no one dared to ask what was the
reason I tried not to let him get fired
after all he was my mentor the respected
researcher as a first known him but even
with my hard work I couldn't convince
the air 5 to let abstain he didn't even
bother to pack his office he doesn't
left that alone with a note in the door
saying for the next guy stuff got passed
around the foundation I lost track of
where most of them went but I know the
Oh father would be looking over all the
things he left just when what they did
with dr. grands when he died I visited
dr. vine from time to time and remained
working for the foundation to this day
my artist was mainly after dr. Fang left
a new researcher while digging through
dr. banks stuff from the long-forgotten
stone it is technically than a CP albeit
not designated any object class on
number the incumbent researcher didn't
find any anomalous properties and just
disposed of the foundation moved on to
more important stuff after all who cares
about a dingy stone with a four line
report the rock was tossed aside along
with other regular foundation garbage
soon as small problems started to pop up
a delivery that was supposed to arrive
in a week took half a month due to
decreased flights an episode of shows
delayed months because of lack of
personnel the highway that was planned
to be built in six months striked into
several years but no one noticed it was
over then normal after all what human
doesn't make mistakes we are fallible
after all they aren't huge problems
anyways a few years before my retirement
I learned that the foundation recovered
the original stone along with several
hundred identical stones from a
secretive extremist group akin to the
chaos insurgency the group laid its
hands on enough to the botched disposal
they found the cause of the stones
properties and must produce the stone
but was then sold to several other
activist groups who started secretly
planting these stones into UN Assemblies
t20 meetings every conference from major
organizations from APEC to NATO stealth
planes flew over municipal 'he's
sprinkling cities with the thin layer of
ground-up precast and i in the dead of
the night an attempt to weaken the major
world players and bring down democracy a
world still went on day by day and
humanity held itself together the
leaders continued to maintain peace with
extremists and the ones who want to
believe that it could bring them victory
were disappointed once again there were
no immediate effects and the extremists
soon turned to other means of bringing
down their enemies a shadow of a stone
lingered seeping into the lives of every
man and affect that no one foresaw
people all around complained about the
general slag but we're just too
apathetic to stand up for it there's
always someone else to blame some other
time to do it Bill's took years to pass
buildings took decades to build and yet
no one seemed to care enough to fix it
soon activist groups fell apart due to
lack of interest labor unions dissolved
because no one had the will to fight for
rights members of parliament bodies were
still active but there were no bills to
pass no issue to debate no conflict to
resolve what was ended because the
soldiers on both sides have lost the
passion and patriotism that brought them
there
the o-5 council tried to prevent the
spread of the phenomenon start the
recovery to let humanity stand back up
in its feet but no matter how hard they
tried agents and research has simply
dragged the missional for years we
didn't die out
we simply lost our will to improve
everyone just didn't care I guess
life was good why change there's always
a later
[Music]
you